JOSH GORDON: Last
episode we trained
in Image Classifier using
TensorFlow for Poets,
and this time, we'll
write one using TF.Learn.
The problem we'll
start on today is
classifying handwritten
digits from the MNIST dataset,
and writing a simple
classifier for these is often
considered the Hello
World of computer vision.
Now MNIST is a multi-class
classification problem.
Given an image of
a digit, our job
will be to predict
which one it is.
I wrote an IPython
notebook for this episode,
and you can find a link
to it in the description.
And to make it easier for you
to configure your environment,
I'll start with a quick
screencast of installing
TensorFlow using Docker.
First, here's an outline
of what we'll cover.
I'll show you how to
download the dataset
and visualize images.
Next, we'll train a
classifier, evaluate it,
and use it to make
predictions on new images.
Then we'll visualize the
weights the classifier learns
to gain intuition for how
it works under the hood.
Let's start by
installing TensorFlow.
You can find
installation instructions
for Docker linked from
the Getting Started page
on TensorFlow.org, and
I'll start this screencast
assuming you've just finished
downloading and installing
Docker itself but haven't
started installing TensorFlow.
Starting from a fresh install
of Docker, the first thing to do
is open the Docker
Quickstart terminal.
And when this appears,
you'll see an IP address just
below the whale.
Copy it down.
We'll need it later.
Next, we'll launch
a Docker container
with a TensorFlow image.
The image is hosted
on Docker hub,
and there's a link to
that in the description.
The image contains TensorFlow
with all its dependencies
properly configured,
and here's the command
we'll use to download
and launch the image.
But first, let's choose
the version we want.
The versions are on
this page, and we'll
use the latest release.
Now we can copy-paste the
command into a terminal
and add a colon with
the version number.
If this is the first time
you've run the image,
it'll be downloaded
automatically.
And on subsequent runs,
it'll be cached locally.
The image starts automatically,
and by default, it
runs a notebook server.
All that's left for us to
do is to open up a browser
and point it to the IP we jotted
down earlier on port 8888.
And now we have an
IPython notebook
that we can experiment
with in our browser served
by the container.
You can find the notebook for
this episode in the description
and upload it through the UI.
OK.
Now onto code.
Here are the imports we'll use.
I'll use matplotlib to display
images, and, of course,
we'll use TF.Learn to
train the classifier.
All of these are
installed with the image.
Next, we'll download
the MNIST dataset,
and we have a nice
one liner for that.
The dataset contains
thousands of labeled images
of handwritten digits.
It's pre-divided into
train, which is 55,000,
and test, which is 10,000.
Let's visualize a few
of these to get a feel.
This code displays an
image along with its label,
and you might notice
I'm reshaping the image,
and I'll explain why in a bit.
The first image from the
testing set is a seven,
and you can see the example
index as well as the label.
Here's the second image.
Now both of these
are clearly drawn,
but there's a variety
of different handwriting
samples in this dataset.
Here's an image that's
harder to recognize.
These images are low
resolution, just 28
by 28 pixels in grayscale.
Also note they're
properly segmented.
That means each image
contains exactly one digit.
Now let's talk about
the features we'll use.
When we're working
with images, we
use the raw pixels as features.
That's because extracting
useful features
from images, like textures
and shapes, is hard.
Now a 28 by 28 image
has 784 pixels,
so we have 784 features.
And here, we're using the
flattened representation
of the image.
To flatten an image means to
convert it from a 2D array
to a 1D array by unstacking
the rows and lining them up.
That's why we had to
reshape this array
to display it earlier.
Now we can initialize
the classifier,
and here, we'll use
a linear classifier.
We'll provide two parameters.
The first indicates how
many classes we have,
and there are 10, one
for each type of digit.
The second informs
the classifier
about the features we'll use.
Now I'll draw a quick diagram
of a linear classifier
to give you a high level preview
of how it works under the hood.
You could think
of the classifier
as adding up the evidence
that the image is
each type of digit.
The input nodes are on the
top, represented by Xes,
and the output nodes are on
the bottom represented by Ys.
We have one input node for each
feature or pixel in the image
and one output
node for each digit
the image could represent.
Here, we have 784
inputs and 10 outputs.
I've just drawn a few
of them, so everything
fits on the screen.
Now the inputs and outputs
are fully connected,
and each of these
edges has a weight.
When we classify an image,
you can think of each pixel
as going on a journey.
First, it flows
into its input node,
and next, it travels
along the edges.
Along the way, it's multiplied
by the weight on the edge,
and the output nodes
gather evidence
that the image we're classifying
represents each type of digit.
The more evidence we gather,
say on the eight output,
the more likely it is
the image is an eight.
And to calculate how
much evidence we have,
we sum the value of the
pixel intensities multiplied
by the weights.
Then we can predict that the
image belongs to the output
node with the most evidence.
The important part
is the weights,
and by setting them
properly, we can
get accurate classifications.
We begin with random weights,
then gradually adjust them
towards better values.
And this happens
inside the fit method.
Once we have a trained
model, we can evaluate it.
Using the evaluate
method, we see
that it correctly classifies
about 90% of the test set.
We can also make predictions
on individual images.
Here's one that it correctly
classifies, and here's
one that it gets wrong.
Now I want to show you how
to visualize the weights
the classifier learns.
Here, positive weights
are drawn in red,
and negative weights
are drawn in blue.
So what do these
weights tell us?
Well, to understand that,
I'll show four images of ones.
They're all drawn
slightly differently,
but take a look at
the middle pixel.
Notice that it's filled
in on every image.
When that pixel
is filled in, it's
evidence that the image
we're looking at is a one,
so we'd expect a
highway on that edge.
Now let's take a
look at four zeros.
Notice that the
middle pixel is empty.
Although there's lots
of ways to draw zeros,
if that middle
pixel is filled in,
it's evidence against
the image being a zero,
so we'd expect a negative
weight on the edge.
And looking at the
images of the weights,
we can almost see outlines
of the digits drawn
in red for each class.
We were able to visualize
these, because we started
with 784 pixels, and we learned
10 weights for each, one
for each type of digit.
We then reshape the
weights into a 2D array.
OK.
That's it for now.
Of course, there's lots
more to learn about this,
and I put my favorite
links in the description.
Coming up next time, we'll
experiment with deep learning,
and I'll cover in more detail
what we introduced here today.
Thanks very much for watching,
and I'll see you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]